Speaker 1: Let's go next to oh, I don't know. I
mean, it's just so it's so hard to know where to
go. How about Logan from Philly? Logan, you're
on the air. Just barely, it sounds like you're
underwater and your volume is going up and down.
Speaker 2: Or do you try recalling like after
another call, I could try switching.
Speaker 1: Oh, you know what now? It just
got a little better. What's what's on your mind?
Speaker 2: All right. So first of all, Ukraine,
two areas of questions. The first is, do you think
Selenski, as a comic will have like what kind of
influence? Soon, do you think Zelinsky as a comic,
will have influence on what is politically viable
in America? Or already change what is
seen as politically viable in America?
And do you think artists are better suited for
governance as a society because their profession
requires them to understand people and human
nature in a deeper way than politicians do?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I also know there's a lot there.
Let's go through it one by one because I don't
I don't want to get any of it. So first of
all, in terms of what's politically viable
in America, we had sort of an actor president
already and Ronald Reagan, and then we had a
failed businessman in Trump. So like, I don't
even think we need to look at Zelensky to
impact what's viable in America. We've already
we've already kind of seen that. So that's one
piece. The second piece I find more interesting,
which is. Actors, performers are professionals
in how their demeanor and delivery are perceived
by audiences, and so that's a very good skill
for elected officials to have. So I'm not going
around demanding movie stars become politicians
in any way. But I think it's it's definitely clear
that some of the skills that performers have do
lend themselves really well to being public
figures, for sure. Elected officials. Yeah.
OK, now you're really breaking up, so
I'm going to let you go. We were able
to hear the first two questions. It's
just breaking up. It's very, very bad,
but it was great to hear from you. Very,
very interesting question, actually.